do you want to talk about that time
where you were
a english teacher you're an english
teacher i was i was an english teacher
in thailand
um so garan's family
had like a friend and i would like it
was allowed um
in the country for like me to like kind
of help with
like because yeah it was it's all right
i wasn't being illegal you know
stealing thai people's money but um
i was an english teacher for uh children
from the ages of
one to uh four right so you're basically
a daycare
that basically sounds like dates yeah
yeah like i just like kind of did that
is
is a bit exhausting um but i remember
the very first english teaching job she
had so
to to preface sydney loves dogs like oh
my god
like whenever she sees a dog like you
can hear it in a voice because like her
her pup the pitch in her voice she
reaches a frequency that only dogs can
hear
you know
yeah exactly it's like she like her
voice goes into like dog whistle
territory
i remember the first day on the on the
job she uh
she was like dreading it and i remember
i had to drive her to this house
where she had to tutor these kids
private tutor yeah um for like kids that
were like
age seven and eight yeah and i was like
i don't want to go to like this
stranger's house what if they
like rape and kill me and i was like oh
but it's also 8 am and i don't want to
go
yeah so she was like complaining the
entire way there to be like maybe i
should quit now i'm just going to quit
like like
i'm going to go there i'm going to look
the person in the eye and i'm going to
be like you know what this job's not for
me
so we pull up to this house and it's
like it's like a gated house with like a
patio on it
and there are just these they're just
these puppies puppies they were just
born that was just these puppies just
sitting in this patio
the moment sydney looked at them all of
the windows in the neighborhood
shattered
those are puppies right there and then a
woman come a woman comes out
and was like oh are you are you the
teacher no that was the house
yeah i'm like
you're just teaching english while
you're holding like full puppy
why why why are you
that's your english and i'd never seen
sydney like just get out the car as fast
as i had as
she had just realized this was the house
that she was about to teach him
and then obviously i hated english
teaching probably not the best at it
like
i was saying i was like i didn't think
your english was that good to begin with
what the [ __ ] that mean
[Laughter]
because i say words like baby bit or
small
or like eye penetration
repeat after me